what is up there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to continue Brooklyn
nine nine today what episode is it John
it's 4 20. oh what do you know hey
season four anyway guys thank you so
much for being here watch go ahead leave
a like on this video that would mean the
world also be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell also mean a
lot as always falling stretch watch long
as we sing with your own copy available
for a super sexy Rejects
over the patreon page cover a bunch of
stuff exclusively over there with
rational highlights watch along is
included I am ready to do this review
and I'm so ready to do this let's do it
[Music]
just go down 10 minutes ago stupid
criminals have no respect for the people
trying to bust them third time today man
what is going on with you real life
problems deals going down let's go all
right then we're gonna pee
[Music]
pee on him take one of those catheter
things
oh my God he's gonna soil himself
no
pee on the lock it'll loosen it don't
know I'm trying to jump down the stairs
shattered his ankle great let's get him
back to the 99 see if floppy foot and
his friend know where our man's hiding
they don't know
whoa Gina Davis Tina Kershaw I mean yeah
my hero same difference you idiots just
ruined a three-month operation my name
is detective Ignatius Petty feather the
ninth that's I G nation
but hey he got to keep his dignity
what's her last name Gina Gershon oh God
that does not even sound the slightest
bit familiar yeah
she's been buried alive three times I've
only been buried alive once I heard she
doesn't let anyone take her photographs
so that she can still go undercover hey
Rosa delete all the pictures you have of
me I don't have any not even a Splash
Mountain one
oh not even the Splash Mountain ones
we've been on his tail for a while we
know everything about him all the way
down to his favorite Froyo flavor monkey
Berry marshmallow Blaster
you wanna help stop looking for Ocampo
and stay away from my case
not looking for him we're gonna find El
Campo for her and then she's not gonna
be mad anymore dope dope indeed dope so
dope I swear I would rather drink ginger
ale Rosa honestly ginger ale so guy got
stabbed at third Union you know what
that means I got Third Street bagels
nice they've been fighting like little
kids all morning and I can't get them to
stop ordering them to stop it well
that's really all I tried guys why are
you fighting your best friends every
Sunday after church Scully and I have
dinner together at Wing [__] we know
so I went by myself Mr liar and his new
tart Cindy shots what happened to our
bro code badge before Hitchcock oh yeah
so I lied because I didn't want you to
throw a fit do you cuck you're the girl
snowflake known you are
Sam they've been spending time on Reddit
I borrowed Amy's favorite pen and
I lost it how'd you lose it I have a
comstat presentation coming up and I was
toying with the idea of using hand
gestures for emphasis
ladies and gentlemen violent crime has
gone down by 10 percent
threw it off the set
you know I wouldn't worry about it Amy's
like physically incapable of being mad
at you watch this Amy someone lost your
pen girl that pin is my best friend and
I will straight Captain Hull
it's fine it's just a pen
she's going outside right now Hawkins
knows we're working the case I highly
doubt it what makes you say that she
just called and said get over here I
know you're working the case so it
appears you around to something very
good touche well off to death
God's hands now
we know you told us to stop looking for
El Campo but we figured we'd find him
for you I'm not mad I checked out your
files I think he might be our best
option at finding this guy again you
think you can do that can a paring knife
remove a human heart in under a minute
yes I've seen it happen sweet
and who knows if you find the guy I got
I got bottom of my squad Maybe
or maybe one of us could fill it excuse
me what you said better Rosa leave now
oh gosh
if we don't find El Campo let's just do
our jobs and Hawkins will do whatever
she's going to do doesn't have to be a
competition right right right right
right
right right
really and we know he's hard up for cash
we also know that's his primary buyer so
we can see what this guy knows those
Smart Suggestions I say we do Peraltas
yes men win in your face Rosa and all
women everywhere
I ride a custom six uh capacity
Superbike I also ride motorcycles oh
yeah what do you ride oh it's in the
shop right now yeah torque felt low so I
was like bro we got stuff up the torque
kids so I'm gonna treat them like kids
daddy's gonna dish out some daddy
discipline as a fellow Daddy I approve
stop saying Daddy you gotta papa bear I
actually kind of like that one sure
anyway I'm gonna take away something
they love until they stop fighting Papa
Bear punishment daddy like Boyle oh
you'll get your chairs back when you
apologize to each other fine
I'm sorry I ever met you you bald freak
don't you push my death you basic [__]
oh the ranch it's over the floor
oh Jesus
fools
[Music]
I'm gonna count to three there will not
be a four okay fine he was here this
morning but I didn't buy anything here
thank you there will not be a four Die
Hard best movie ever best franchise oh
yeah
I also like Die Hard
really Rosa what what's your favorite
part the shootouts interesting vague and
interesting
favorite movies were made by Nancy Myers
seriously what no I hate that crap
really so you hate the one starring
Diane Keaton and John Wick what was it
called again I don't know something has
to give something's got to give I gotcha
damn embarrassing Rosa women women
everywhere who got the warrant for
Diaz's tap called his brother and
arranged to meet up it's about to go
down so it looks like my idea worked
after all did it though yes it did nice
job Diaz she's intentionally pitting
them against each other that's right
that's so [__] hot
do it to us
[Laughter]
that's fun I can't wait to drive this
motorcycle that I definitely know how to
drive
[Music]
laughs
that's nice good fake out just say the
word and I will tell you off okay tell
me off about losing your pen oh makes me
feel pretty annoyed no it grates my
cheese I mean oh Santiago you're faking
faking what did you hear that girl just
admit it okay fine I was faking the
whole time but I only did it because I
wanted you to enjoy it that ruins it uh
could he make you angry well you know
what I don't want to know don't tell me
I don't want to know
I'm sure it's a great repurposing of
that talk I see what's happening this is
a competition we're officially competed
and I'm gonna Crush you also I need a
ride can I please sit on the back of
your motorcycle no well played looks
like I'm gonna find out if a motorcycle
fits on the subway
[Laughter]
finally hydrated and it's unlocking my
brain's full potential and does if it's
laced with caffeine oh no that is cruel
oh when nikolaj and his best friend
fight I have them do an activity
together like a puppy puzzle make some
cooperate so are you saying we give
Hitchcock and Skelly a case and make
them work it together no no we give him
a puppy puzzle
daddy style all right I need you guys to
assemble this jigsaw puzzle for a case
I'm working on what can't argue with
that
damn Boyle that is some advanced level
parenting right there I learned from the
best thank you I guess being a daddy
just comes naturally to me
oh my God
sure caffeine speeds you up but half and
half slows you down
oh no Dairy
oh excuse me Jay just called oh did he
pass his final no but he said ocampo's
in a warehouse on the corner of
Richardson Lefferts
what's wrong Rosa out of gas
oh it was horrible but still not as bad
as water see it never
what's wrong Jake out of steering wheels
you know that I am
okay I can run too you're both gonna
lose this I want my officers to respect
the chain of command but I never want
anyone to be so terrified of me that
they repress a basic emotions you need
to turn in your badge halt you're an
abusive Overlord this is about me and my
issues with authority you've been great
wrong I've been a disaster I can't
believe blame yourself
free if you lost my pen that was
perilous and rude and it was a real jerk
move Santiago
of you playing your damn classical music
in your office all day we can all hear
it okay well this has been shut your
mouth when I'm talking to you right too
far I'm sorry this is all very new for
me
frisbee in the trunk and I taped it on
that's right I'm Guyver the dunk out of
this thing and it worked flawlessly the
group I hit a ton of stuff on the way
over
second that we find him we go back to
being Arch Rivals no two ways about it
yep I'll boil your flesh and drink from
your skull yeah totally I'll do that to
you too if I win we're both doing a
ticks
[Laughter]
[Music]
he is good at locking people out oh yeah
feels like a setup I mean he could have
opened the door but stayed inside to
triggers no wait this guy's not that
smart
oh
my God
[Music]
oh my God he's gonna take him down and
then Rose is Gonna Save him no he's in
here somewhere
so much more room I know it's gonna take
down Peralta you're under never mind I
have to pee while I hold you at gunpoint
I've been drinking so much water and
caffeine geez diuretics dude it's just
our Captain's a man our Sergeant's a man
every Superior officer I've ever had has
been a man just seemed cool to work for
a badass woman like Hawkins oh my God
I can't hear a word you're saying right
now through all the woke
we failed as parents why did I think I
knew what I was doing poor nikolage his
life is ruined my God you two are fools
yes
[Laughter]
they're not children they're not adults
they're animals filthy wild animals stop
it stop it right now but he won't let me
know
we better apology please I'm sorry for
neglecting our friendship well I'm sorry
too you're my best friend good boys
stay stays eat it
God I'm gonna make a great dad someday
damn do you really do that way to go
and you'll never guess where we found
him
not going he was hiding I ruined the
story
and I'm announcing that the person
joining your task force is detective
Diaz because you said we should split up
it was the correct call yeah but you
brought him in you won agree to disagree
I say you won I think you won I say you
won
you've got each other's backs
I like that loyalty
important thing to me so I tell you what
I'm going to do how about I'm going to
put you both on the task force it's a
fine idea not that we really cared I
wasn't really listening what are we
talking about
are we hugging have we ever done this
before no if you tell anyone I'll slit
your throat oh thank you so much Jake
please I'm just glad you finally get to
work for a woman as badass as you are
and as a man I'd like to apologize for
my gender story now okay all right I
promise you I will never drink water
ever again thank God it's the worst BRB
PRP
[Music]
oh my God is she a criminal oh no she's
making out with the guy Samus can get me
for these
I'm trying not to get caught this time
oh no
dirty
no I don't trust women yeah
women decades with this move Jesus her
reasoning is probably like oh being in
this position as a woman is
tough so I've had to resort to these
other measures because um because
[Music]
thank you yes that's right
don't forget it I am mad why'd they say
Batman is a fascist yeah what about my
rights I am so upset Princess Peach can
do stuff no no my peach not my peach and
the games but I ignored them release why
are there women being adapted from their
comments dude I am upset yeah
can't handle it man I think we should
burn it all down
yup yup yup yup anyway guys
um that was fun
that was really fun that was really fun
I had a fun time I had a fun time
absolutely uh it's interesting how
they've really fleshed out Hitchcock and
Scully
yep the way I say his name by the way is
always a uh half pronounced way of doing
it which one Scully yeah because I'm I'm
always like
oh yeah sure because there are a lot of
notable sullies some leaders going and
I'm like they're just kind of like this
college hi like where if like I don't
know if he said to see but I wasn't
strong enough to to question it or not
I say it a certain way where you hear it
because you expect to hear the right
name yeah totally you just fill it in
yeah I understood how to do it your
brain does that all the time but the way
they have fleshed them out is fun
because they are like animals and that
is who they are and I have no idea why
they are the way they are and how
they've managed to maintain this
position and the fact that this show
deals so much with enabling of terrible
behaviors too yeah they look out for
these guys they do you know if they they
ought to have been fired plain and
simple they should have been fired but
you got people who constantly get into
these Superior positions even characters
like Holt who for some reason they just
can't seem to let go of its trial of
bond relationship really so oh most
certainly no I mean the whole array of
psychological uh turmoil and clashing
that they revealed through Amy and Holt
alone was really you know kind of uh uh
traumatic to to experience here just
through this episode I mean you know
trying to unlock that place of anger
that people buried down is a real thing
and it can rot you to your core and Amy
is certainly experienced the effects of
that across this Four Seasons that we
watched so far yeah because in that
moment she was not standing up against
Holt she was standing up against her mom
and dad that's right all the things she
never said take that Jimmy Smits why do
you think she puts all that control into
these other monotonous things things
that don't really matter I mean what
kind of individual must you be do you
consider a pen to be your best friend
sure man it's very sad
an inanimate object come on that's
ridiculous yeah yeah marry it or you let
it be in inanimate it can't be in
between it's silly absolutely silly uh
but you know that's her own struggles
that she has to deal with as well
absolutely and also Hulk trying to
develop this relationship with the
daughter he never had
the same time he probably wants her name
into his mom as we saw what she's like
disciplinary stands up speaks her voice
much [__] my daughter my mother my
daughter my mother
clearly Rose didn't have a good role
model either no no I mean you know she's
violent and uh you know she she has
trouble connecting to her own emotions
you know she could easily become a
serial killer if he wasn't on the right
side of the law and I feel like that's
something that we need to unpack well
the amount of damage that they do uh to
each other I mean look at they treat the
police station with Hitchcock and Scully
sure look at what they did with
motorcycles vehicles in here this is the
taxpayer's money and they just take
advantage and abuse the system this show
is really a political commentary on the
police official system yeah an aptitude
of of our law enforcement sure
definitely
take that dick wolf they're not really
trying to serve the people they're
self-serving oh sure that's what's
happening they're trying to serve
Hitchcock and Scully you know so it all
boils down to let people fail upward in
this game I mean I just see what like
Terry and and boiler doing in their
police station and they're in their
positions and the amount of attention
they put into trying to parent they're
clearly trying to work through their own
parental struggles in their private
lives and bringing it to the office and
that's just not a professional matter
no but that's the thing they could call
this show unprofessional 99 just because
it's a Showcase of all the things not to
do in the workplace it's disgusting yeah
and it made a mockery of staying well
hydrated which I think is the greatest
defense because that's one of the most
Elemental things you can do as a human
being of any variety like one thing that
brings us all together is the need for
pure water and just the anti-water
agenda across this episode was frankly
shocking and I am going to be writing
the Fox network
to complain about this fox
or NBC
um I just assumed you know edginess you
know whenever anything edgy or wantonly
uh harsh or or you know uh pulpey
happens I just assume it was the fox
never but you know it's a it's a whole
game of heathens now it's a it's a
Godless and uh
you know hateful Satan inspired media
that we live in and uh yeah I'm just
gonna write them all what do you think
about uh Gina Carano Gina Carano should
be back on the Mandalore
uh I liked Gina Davis a lot in this
episode Gina Gershon uh she is the right
role model you know she's making the
most out of both her position as a law
enforcement officer but she's also uh
working to make crime a slightly more
qualitative in this city and in this
country and I I appreciate that she's
not out here American people she's out
here trading diamonds and uh you know I
feel like we could all learn a little
entrepreneurial Acumen from that choice
she's gay in real life is she really
I'm assuming that's cool that's exciting
yeah for I guess yeah I would add to uh
the boundness
is regarded as a gay icon ooh
let's see
is Gina Gershon gay this
kit
kitschmix.com says that she is not
but uh she's not but she's a gay icon
but she's a gay icon for for playing so
many different gay roles I guess
um oh she is straight says it here
apparently a quote from her oh dude
I'm not a lesbian but I play one in the
movies oh and she he Gina Gershon
recently came out as straight that's a
that's a sentence I didn't see some
foreigners do American accents some
people play action heroes some straight
people consistently play gay people some
white people play Asian people for like
a whole passage of a movie that's crazy
sure I always thought she was gay I did
too or at least I don't know bisexual or
something like that not just
definitively
hetero
it shows the rain she has that's right
man yeah can't I'm mind blown mind blown
right now G I tell you
it's hard to swallow that pill well now
I can think she's hot that's true
because before I couldn't that's right
that is disrespectful to the gay
community sure I suppose yeah now she's
hot and that's what we've learned today
is is the appropriate times for people
to be hot that's right I think it's good
that's right she was in showgirls
[Music]
yeah showgirl she was she was just your
face off
not just I just watched face off and she
was in it so yeah she's been in it since
1997. I'm pretty sure no copies exist
where she's been removed
I don't know that I'm sure someone's
been like you know what I I love
everything about this but I just can't
watch Gina Gersh I hate cut her out
Topher Grace probably has a cut
somewhere she doesn't she's not gay in
that no dude actually so she's
aggressively straight this is very
straight like so straight yeah she tries
to force herself on Caster Troy but not
and then it's all awkward and then he's
a good guy
so straight
I don't think we covered everything that
we need to cover yes sincerely and uh
inappropriately of course yeah
yeah I'm looking forward to the eventual
Switcheroo where they're like nah she's
a triple agent and actually this is all
part of her plan and Jake and Amy or
Jake and Rose are going to screw it up
they just needed an excuse to not have
them actually graduate from Brooklyn
Nine-Nine yeah I might start going like
oh
how are they gonna do the show yeah what
are they going to do they're gonna
divide it up or they're gonna have two
separate sections we cut between like
thunder Mifflin oh sure season three
get your Andy uh Andy what's his name in
the show
new whole ensemble camera Andy Bar uh or
you're close
isn't that the Chucky character Andy
Barkley he has the turkey Chucky
character yeah who's who's that helps
it's Gina gershon's in yes is she yes
she is that's right of course she's in
there I want to have a couple episodes
one episode
yeah it was good boundary Union further
uh solidifying
playing into I don't know
because of that isn't she like clearly
very sexuality fluid I don't know
Chucky is working
she's into Jennifer Tilly that's right
there you go yeah see that's what I'm
remembering and I was remembering that
as though it was like a real life
account
instead of friction but uh but yeah
dude Gina Gershon it's the gershon's now
she back
what things are you saying
you know I just I just try to act like
an antenna patron of the day shout out
David Gandy
David
you'd be a great lesbian no sure I would
love for you to be a lesbian make it
happen I think that there's just
something about your qualities
that doesn't quite scream gay guy
doesn't scream hetero guy
but it does that really feels less
lesbian sure let's be in quality about
you that I really like I can't quite put
my finger on it but no it's in his
energy I I get what you mean yeah
yeah there's sort of like a nice it's
like it's soft but not without an edge
you know it's just a specific kind of
array of uh yeah of uh of tenderness but
also assertiveness we like to Crown
people certain titles and specific
attributes at our patreon page and I
would say David you're the lesbian of
our patreon page yeah if we boil what it
means to be a lesbian down into a basic
monolith you are the the Incarnation of
white
male
lesbian David Gandy that is your
business car that's a good title
yeah wml David Gandy you are one good
looking lesbian
and an even better looking white male
lesbian
well David I appreciate you being here
you can't see it but I hung the thing
you got us oh yeah it looks nice it's
way over there it's over for me to look
at where I edited it's so it's next to a
personalized painting from Olivia too so
that's how you know it's like a special
part of the wall yeah
it's right over there yeah we can't pass
it because it'll ruin everything to the
rejects from your favorite lesbian
Dave again stay Sapphic
[Applause]